hallo alle zusammen und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video heute
mit anja von jim webb anja learned that
anja ist heute bei uns zu gast und wir
haben uns heute etwas ganz besonderes
ausgedacht vor kurzem ich schon mal ein
video darüber gemacht wie man in
deutschland streitet und heute geht es
noch eine spur härter nämlich neben
straßenverkehr das ist würde ich sagen
eine der lieblings tätigkeiten von
deutschen das denke ich auch auf jeden
fall da haben wir schon viele
erfahrungen gemacht oder anderen ich
zeige euch heute mal wieso über was sich
deutsche so streiten und vision streit
ablaufen kann und ich will sagen los
gehts ja geht mal zur seite wann
[Musik]
entschuldigung könnten sie ja vielleicht
weg gehen
hallo
könnten sie das vielleicht weg gehen
selbst ihre kopfhörer auch nicht ich
fass es nicht
hallo hallo
nehmen sie mal über ohrhörer ab können
sie vielleicht aus dem weg gehen ich
möchte gerne durchfahren sagen sie mein
fahrrad ist kaputt gedanken schreiben
sie mal ganz ruhig bleiben sie mal ganz
ruhig ja aber das können sie ja
vielleicht auch minuten ganz ehrlich
also das können wir vielleicht auch am
straßenrand machen oder fragen sie mal
ganz ruhig sie sitzen da in ihrem auto
entspannen sie sich die einteiler
heiliger
bleiben sie ruhig und sie können auch
selber laufen oder fahrradfahrer ritz
machen können nicht so an mich hier
jetzt machen sie mich mal nicht so an
hier vielleicht bewegen sie sich den
ganzen tag nicht sitzen deinen safari
und savanne roman ich glaube es hackt
für höhere steuern jetzt drängt da
konnten sie sie decken die nachbarn ja
auch ich sehe auch die nachbarn bleiben
sie mal ruhig und in der welt helfen
wir haben sie ihr vater kind sitzen und
rom mit und ist schon klar ja das kann
ich auch machen
typisch basteln typisch deutsch
was dann kommt sie doch mal steigen sie
auf ihre leistungen aussteigen ich mal
in ihrem leben einen fahrrad auf gefällt
bewegen sich jemand mal wieder
aufgepumpt wissen sie was ist dann sind
sie doof oder was sagen sie mal sind sie
doof oder was bloehte blöde kuh
ich bin ne blöde kuh jetzt mach dich mal
weg da aber zacki jetzt aber zacki
glaube es hackt echt erste grinsen dann
auch so blöd jetzt vater ein fahrrad aus
dem weg aber ganz schnell sonst rufe ich
die polizei
naja da gucken sie aber da gucken sie
aber ich hatte jetzt auch keine zeit
mich mit ihnen weiter zu reden ganz
ehrlich wegen solcher menschen wie jene
ohne ich nicht mehr in deutschland
rheinhausen
dann schauen sie doch ab
entschuldigung das ist eine
einbahnstraße sich und wieder
ich fasse es nicht das ist das von
grünanlagen und jetzt warten sie schon
wieder auf die unschuldigen
fahrradfahrer hier damit sie die
schnecke machen können hat nein das sich
nach aber diesmal ist sie kann aber sie
stehen also ist nicht nach hause müssen
dafür einmal schnell lernen sie mich
denn hier sind sie eigentlich blöd mach
mich nicht an ich mache sie an mir
natürlich wir haben das theater hier
auch nicht so ein theater
sie fand in die falsche richtung dadurch
gefährden sie andere verkehrsteilnehmer
ist irgendwas bewusst nein das ist mir
nicht bewusst ja dann denken sie darüber
nach die währungen sind ja schlesien
wirklich so was die user haben sie denn
keine anderen probleme haben sie denn
keine anderen probleme
und ehrlich gesagt nicht mir geht's gut
denn nicht jeder hat solche leute wie
sie die studenten oder so oder aber
schon so gut
ihnen geht es zu gut im leben arbeitet
sich etwas ernsthafteren youtube videos
auf youtube bis sagen berufen oder was
ist das ein beruf oder was kennt die uci
das ist erfunden meine zwölfjährigen
kommen
naja also wissen sie
da waren immer videos auf youtube und
verstoßen gegen die regel nicht leid
dass sie so typisch deutschen und so
unzufrieden sind mit ihrem leben als sie
müssen dass ich an mir auslassen
das machen sie doch mal platzt sie
behindern schon wieder den verkehr wenn
ich zu fassen
jetzt seid ihr dran als erstes freuen
wir uns sehr wenn ihr unsere beiden
youtube-kanäle abonniere genau german
mit anja und easy german da bekommt ihr
dann nämlich immer ganz viele tolle
videos und vor allem vergessen sich die
klingel zu drücken denn nur dann bekommt
ihr auch wirklich nachrichten wenn ein
neues video von anja oder von uns
draußen ist und wir wollen unbedingt von
euch wissen habt ihr schon mal
irgendwelche verrückten situationen im
deutschen straßenverkehr erlebt genau
schreibt das mal in die kommentare
unbedingt an ja du hast so etwas noch
nie erlebt so wie heute noch immer zu
wenn ich in deutschland bin zum glück
bin ich nicht so oft hier
das ist der grund warum er genau wissen
das ist wirklich wahr
das kann nicht verstehen ist eine der
sachen die ich in deutschland nicht so
sehr mag denn deutsche mögen die
verkehrsregel sehr so sehr das ist nicht
jedermanns sache also wenn ihr nach
deutschland kommt müsst ihr manchmal
damit rechnen
wir freuen uns dass sie zugeschaut hat
danke dass du zu gast waren ja ja wir
sehen uns bald wieder hier kein einem
jahr vielleicht eventuell an john wird
anja abonnieren und hier könnt ihr sie
dämmen abonnieren
blöde kuh ist noch ganz gut warum denn
das ist doch nicht schlimm enden sie
doch mal ganz ruhig man muss nicht